then beasts of the southern wild there's
a real love letter to Louisiana and I
know you've lived there since about 2006
but how did it change the way you felt
about the area having made the film yeah
well you know I've been living in New
Orleans since 2006 but this movie kind
of took me to another part of Louisiana
all the way south down the bayou in
South Terrebonne Parish and it's a
totally different culture down there and
so that was like a really new experience
for me
to get to know you know New Orleans is a
city and and the place where the film
was shot is really you know a town that
sort of thrives on fishing and used to
thrive on out on agriculture and stuff
and so it was it was really interesting
thing to kind of get out of the city and
go into the wild and you know kind of
make a film up against nature curve
engine a you play the film's lead what
was it like acting opposite beasts that
weren't actually there on set further
pre-start and like we just drew one and
we just saw how it looked and we were
like okay that let's go to the real
scene and we did the real scene we had
it straight on so we didn't have to do
it what's been like the director is he a
hard taskmaster sometimes I do it a lot
of times though sometimes I do a lot of
takes one time he saying you what did
you enjoy most about playing hush puppy
she was fun hard-working and she would
do what she was supposed to do
we'd be friends with her in real life if
she existed and she will wear pants
together Ben how did you discover quiver
engine a she she came into an audition
in Terrebonne Parish Library you know
right near where we shot the film and it
was part of a massive kind of grassroots
casting search that we did for nine
months and looked at 4,000 kids and you
know thankfully through probably a
series of coincidences she just want
came into the audition and you know we
were you know when you wouldn't you
decide you're gonna make your film with
a six year old star you're essentially
banking on a miracle and you know we we
got one when she when we found her I
know it was a very collaborative process
with all the actors so how did the
character of hushpuppy change when cove
enginee came on board um she became very
wise and one of the things that struck
me about her from the first time she
came in is that she always had there was
never a subject that she didn't have an
opinion on or an idea about and so you
know it was really interesting to me you
know when you when you write a child
character you don't necessarily think of
them as a kind of sort of sage Wiseman
almost but but she had that quality and
so that was always an element of
hushpuppy that she would speculate about
stuff but when when we cast Cove engine
a it became this almost voice of wisdom
throughout throughout the film and a lot
of her ideas ended up getting written
into the voice-over and written into the
way that she thought about the world how
did you go about coaxing such a natural
performance from Cove NJ in the film
because obviously it all hinges on that
doesn't it yeah I mean you know it was a
performance you know she's she's not and
she's not hush puppy she's her own
person and we had to work ourselves into
the emotions for the scene so it was
kind of the two of us kind of pushing
each other jackin each other up and I
remember I remember you know there's one
scene where she had to be really mad and
she said I'm not mad enough you need to
tell me how mad need to be you gotta
tell me if I need to be yellow angry red
angry or purple angry I was like well
which is the most angry and she said
well purple is the most and that and I
said okay well I want purple and she
said no no no I've only purple as you
don't want purple you want red so she
did red angry you know but that's how it
was you know we'd figure out what the
emotion was and we get ourselves there
you also cost a local Baker Dwight
Henry's Hush Puppies father
tell me about that yeah well that was a
real New Orleans story I mean you know
we we knew him because he was across the
street at the bakery and we figured you
know okay well we don't have to worry
about where to find mr. Henry he's gonna
be at Henry's bakery but then we went
back and Henry's was closed we thought
he could have
town we have no idea what could have
happened to him and then eventually his
new bakery opened and we found him there
and it took a lot of kind of coaxing to
convince him to take the part because
he's really committed to his bakery and
so we basically just had to find a way
that the film and the bakery could
collaborate and coexist and we just
ended up doing all our work while he was
baking and that allowed him to do the
film what's going to be next for you
guys now queer engine hey do you want to
go on acting yes what about you Ben yeah
I want to keep directing but you know I
mean um you know I really love the way
that we made this film is this really
special kind of like family operation
and you know my intention is really they
sort of keep that going keep on
developing that kind of grassroots way
of working you know I'm hoping to bring
back a lot of the same team people and
just get a chance to do this again
you